Community Brighton 8 news now is
sponsored by Our Community Pride
Partners Finley Automotive Group
Southwest Medical part of Optum care and
Silver State Schools Credit Union
Southwest Medical is celebrating 50
years of serving patients in Las Vegas
and Dr John Rhodes is here with us to
take a look at the last half century as
well as a look toward the future of
serving medical needs in southern Nevada
thanks for being here thank you for
having me actually this is a celebration
that's been going on all year so it is
it is we started celebrating at the
beginning of the year so if you think
back
uh 1972 Dr Tony Marlin a local
cardiologist started his practice here
and then quick quickly uh had another
provider family doctor join him and they
became a multi-specialty group and that
really became the foundation for once
that became Southwest Medical today yeah
it's a home-grown practice which you
know something about as well it is a
homegrown practice and I do born and
raised here uh here in Las Vegas I went
to school here did College medical
school here and have now practiced in
southern Nevada spanning four decades I
hate to say started when you were
in the meantime 50 years there have been
so many Innovations so many developments
in that span what are some of the most
notable ones you know you're right
medicine is obviously expanded a lot but
but Southwest Medical has brought a lot
of that to our community and our
communities really benefited uh from
that uh starting in 1972 and then we
were actually the first Health
maintenance organization in Nevada and
uh so we were part of uh starting that
up and then we were the first to bring
on electronic medical records so we were
the first to advance that in a large
group in the state and continue to uh
use that today telemedicine which
through covet a lot of people became uh
more known about in Virtual visits Yeah
we actually started that quite a while
back so we were prepared as covet came
and had been Innovative that and
expanding that yeah and now practice and
now it's looking toward the next 50
years what do you think things on the
horizon so I think it will be uh more
telemedicine using technology and stuff
to help Advance what we're doing make us
uh better at what we're doing make us
more efficient uh what we're doing but
what's interesting is we bring all this
technology but it comes down to a
patient still want to sit in the exam
room and be be with their friends they
still want to see the friendly face of
Dr John Rhodes and doctors like you
thanks so much for being here so thank
you really appreciate it all right Rocky
over to you